[Music]
what's up you guys time again for the
matinee show this is matinee episode 62
yeah
three good ones I know the Lighting's
kind of weird in here today I guess cuz
we were filming this earlier we had to
like shut the door to keep the yeah
light from blowing out so so we actually
did get to the theatre one time this
week so we'll be reviewing that at the
end but the other two are Netflix movies
both of them Netflix originals I think
yeah and the first one we're going to
talk about is rattlesnake which is not
at the end of October of this year
that's pretty good it was pretty good um
I it's weird because I'd like I said I
don't read reviews of the movies
beforehand but I did see like
percentages you know what I mean while
I'm kind of looking for a plot rundown
the percentages on this were like men
like half and half some people liked it
some people not so much it's actually it
was written and directed by Zach
Hilditch who was the same guy that
directed the other the Stephen King
adaptation 1922 that was also a Netflix
original which was actually very good
and I would recommend it this one almost
kind of seems like a Stephen King story
a little bit it has it has that kind of
vibe to it um I didn't really know like
how it was gonna go when I started
watching it and I kind of recommend that
so I'm gonna try not to spoil it
basically what the what the plot of it
is there's just this woman and her
daughter the daughters name is Clara
she's like oh I guess she's seven or
eight or something like that and they're
driving across Texas I think they're
trying to get to Oklahoma and I'm
assuming they don't really tell you till
later but I'm assuming she's like
leaving her husband or whatever she's
starting over or whatever so they're
driving across the desert and there's an
accident she has to get off the highway
and her um you know GPS on her phone
goes out because she loses her signal
and then she gets a flat tire and while
she's like stop trying to fix the tire
her daughter gets bitten by a
rattlesnake and the gun creepily so
she's like flipping out she can't get a
phone signal and everything creepily she
sees like a trailer sitting by a
self like out in the middle of nowhere
that you're pretty sure wasn't there
before so she goes she takes her
daughter in there and the woman that's
in there is like super weird and she's
like oh I can help and blah blah blah
and from there things get a little
strange yeah she heals the kid but then
this kind of demonic guy shows up later
and tells her that in exchange for
healing that kid she's got to kill
somebody and deliver his soul so she
Cana she doesn't believe it at first but
then she gets convinced there's but
there's paranormal stuff happens yeah
and she goes out and tries to select a
person to kill that's part of the movie
in order to save the daughter it's
pretty cool it's it's kind of old-school
storytelling in terms of for this kind
of like he says kinda almost kind like
an ad Stephen King yeah it reminded me
of that like maybe like riding the
bullet or something like that like that
type of vibe it had save a lot of desert
action kind of sometimes kind of
reminded me of I don't know the hitch
the hitch-hiker of The Hitcher The
Hitcher yeah that's your kind of remind
me so you know it's just yeah you know
it's just a drive a movie it's just
something you put on your watch you go
yeah that's pretty cool you know think
but it's not like a blockbuster that's
not well yeah and like I said I'm not
supposed to be there yeah this was a
perfectly enjoyable game thriller
mystery I don't know if I'd call it a
horror movie exactly even though it does
have kind of like a supernatural element
but it does kind of fall in that area
where you could sorta call it a horror
movie it's more like a thriller I guess
supernatural thriller supernatural
suspense adventure right yeah and and
actually I think I enjoyed it more like
not really knowing what direction it was
going and you know what I mean because I
didn't expect it to go necessarily in a
supernatural direction although you
figure it out pretty early because you
know after the girl gets bit by the
rattlesnake and she's you know dying and
everything with that then you see the
trailer and I'm like wait a minute that
trailer wasn't there and then this
creepy woman is and then she heals the
kid and then I'm like okay we're going
it or descending into paranormal kind of
[ __ ] here this is so this is kind of
like a thing where or
well at first I was kind of like well
maybe the woman is just kind of you know
maybe the mom is just kind of like
imagining it because we watched a movie
that was on Netflix awhile back that was
kind of about that was like that we're
like this bad [ __ ] happened and then I
can't remember the name of it right now
it was like a few like a month or two
ago that we were reviewed it we're bad
[ __ ] happened like a little girl got
killed or you thought she got killed and
then the dad like um you know he goes to
the hospital then they disappeared you
know what I mean so that so there was
that whole thing so this kind of had
that kind of vibe to it I think I
probably liked this one a little bit
better just because I thought it was
cool that I that I didn't really know
that it was going in that direction it's
just a well-made low-budget movie linear
storytelling pretty traditional you'd
have to worry about any kind of
subversion of your expectations or
anything yeah you don't know how it's
gonna go down but it's just it's just
solid but it keeps you like interest
yeah it keeps you invested in the
mystery and then once she figures out
like what she has to do to keep her
daughter alive then it kind of then it
kind of because we were sitting there
are talking about it's like what would
we do in this situation like who would
we kill you know so it's like and she
does like pretty logical [ __ ] like she
goes through like the logical [ __ ] that
you would think of you know what I mean
um also the guy that's in this we were
watching it and the one guy who's like
an [ __ ] that she's kind of like
gunning for with the whole time we were
like goddammit who is that guy he's like
so familiar so we had to like look him
up because we couldn't remember he had
shades on Luke Cage yeah as soon as I
soon as I searched that dude's name and
saw him in the suit I immediately
recognized him from Luke Cage series
yeah oh yeah he was a he was a great
character he did he really I like I
really liked him it did a good job in
this movie - it's just good movie yeah
like I said it's it's like a lot of
Netflix originals where it's like you
know nothing to throw a party over
anything but it's a perfectly enjoyable
spare and watching just [ __ ] you can
wash it
watching literal [ __ ] yeah it's like I
wish it
you'll be like man [ __ ] this this one
that it's like you said it's on par with
a lot of the Netflix originals which are
just like which they're not good they're
good you know they're not like
oscar-winning like mind-blowing like oh
my god that that's my favorite movie
ever but it's like a perfectly enjoyable
way to spend a Friday night a lot better
than a b-movie yeah you know so you know
but if if you're kind of in the mood for
something like that kind of a
supernatural thriller technology leaving
kingi time to have a king a type thing
with like you know kind of some nice big
desert vistas like yeah and I'm kind of
like The Hitcher type of a hit you and
hills have eyes you know there aren't
any mutants in it but there's a bunch of
like desert hunting people down in the
desert caverns and [ __ ] like that now
that you mentioned it it is kind of like
The Hitcher because that almost kind of
had like a little bit of a supernatural
it did or it could have had a sequel to
it I mean this one it was much more
overt that it was supernatural even
though you could argue that the whole
thing happened in her head but I don't I
don't think it did because she finds out
later that there's like all these work
murders yeah The Devil's involved in
devil and either it's a witch it's
either witch of the devil it's up to you
yeah because the figure she keeps seeing
is that woman from the trailer he was oh
she's only you only see her like at the
beginning in the trailer but then in the
rest of it she's kind of like this
shadow like yeah almost like she's some
demonic or she's the devil and the devil
and that the Dead come back and give
warnings and there's one of them that's
kind of like a familiar either that or
this is the devil and he's a demon it's
just up it's up to us of them to
interpretation yeah definitely but you
know it's pretty cool too you know
pretty cool movie to check
you
all right so the second one also in
Netflix original this one actually came
out way back in March I believe but
somebody requested this that we do this
one and we didn't review it at the time
it came out even though we did watch it
again well yeah but we watched it again
we were gonna review it this is the dirt
yeah story of Molly the Motley Crue
biopic yeah it's good because you know
they tell you that it isn't totally
accurate when they change things they
said well it didn't actually have it
that way but yeah which reminded me of
24 Hour Party People yes it was kind of
the kind of the the official story of
you know what went down with them and
how they formed and their lives and you
know what happened with the car
accidents and the heroin overdoses and
children dying from cancer it's a
terrible show every guys everybody's
screwing everybody else's girlfriends
and wives what's that there's the kind
of women they attracted I think well
that's Hipple groupies and groupie type
women although Heather Locklear was
Astra stand-up chick but eventually even
Tommy Lee like screw run over yeah he
was like screw a porn stars nothing yeah
but apparently this movie because this
is based on the book you know that was
written by all four members of motley
crew you know along with neil strauss i
think was the author that helped him out
with it that came out like more than a
decade ago apparently they've been
trying to get this movie made since like
2006 right like MTV Films was gonna do
it like paramount was gonna do it and
then I guess they [ __ ] around for too
long or they you know they wanted too
much money I don't know what the problem
was but they somehow they just never got
around to doing it and then finally I
think Netflix bought like the worldwide
rights to the book in 2017 and then they
started finally filming it I will say
that like all the actors that they got
to play the members of Motley Crue were
like really good yeah they're funny um
they're really funny the movie is like
it's not real I've seen it called like 1
review of it that I read I've seen it
called like an r-rated Wikipedia article
which I could see like they said that
there wasn't like a whole lot of like
substance to it but it's like fun to
watch you know yeah you need to move you
reminds me very much of Howard Stern's
biography was it the private yeah yeah
it reminds me a lot of that movie if you
like that movie or like this one it's
comedy yeah basically a comedy even
though like a lot a lot of tragedies a
lot of I mean cuz you know it and I feel
like because I'm not a big Motley Crue
fan I mean like I said I think Motley
Crue's heyday was like when I was in
junior high or like early years of high
school and you know I was more into like
post-punk New Wave that type of stuff
and it are nebith nemec's were the
people that listened to Motley Crue
because back in the 80s like the people
that listened to Motley Crue were like
kind of the jock like meathead types or
metalheads - or metalhead it was a
little mainstream I me that it was a
little mainstream even for me I was
obviously into metal really at that time
I think I had the first two albums yeah
I don't think I bought the third one and
their first albums were pretty good yeah
too fast for love I liked it kind of had
a kind of a fast goth Punk kind of
influence to it yes you know early in
the scene in LA and shout at the devil
was almost kind of like a it was
actually like a kiss album except every
song was good on it yeah that was the
difference because you bought a kiss
album in it it's like what are two good
well good songs they do it they're doing
it how to make money lunchboxes that's
what they did yeah I think we've and I
had a kiss lunchbox and I do like kiss I
just thought the lunchbox is cool but I
always liked that I always liked the
band and I liked what they were doing
back in the day back in the day yeah
they were some would say that it was a
kiss copy by the time shadow the devil
came out and maybe it was a kiss copy
but it still worked and yeah they did it
a little bit better it was more updated
I think he's so much face well their
songs generally like you said we're
better than they were they were better
both songs yeah they were better than
kiss you know kiss could kiss had some
[ __ ] awesome songs yeah they did even
though in that Animalize out album had
like one good song on it
but that was there that was their
marketing I think yeah this was just
okay we're gonna put out an album yeah
how many good songs you wanna play yeah
because they were trying to make as many
albums kiss was trying to make as many
albums as they could they knew that
their fans would buy it yeah it was like
buying a single when you were bought an
album was more like you were buying a
single with a bunch of bass like a lot
of albums but no it was it's a good
movie you know especially if you kind of
grew up during that time or you know and
kind of brought some stuff back there's
some iconic scenes where dude shows up
what's his name Ozzy Osbourne shows up
at the pool and snorts have a bunch of
line a line dance pisses on the ground
licks of his own piss and then [ __ ]
Tommy it was a time of leave I think it
was Tommy Lee that was like hissed on
the ground for he's like trying to like
one up in which that may have been that
may have been something that they that
was maybe something that they actually
did because these dudes were dorks
really I mean people that don't hang
around with [ __ ] bands or don't know
anybody you know I mean it oh man it
kind of that's cool you know not really
this is a [ __ ] darks well you're
young and dumb you know no man and it's
trying to be rock stars and doing stupid
[ __ ] yeah that's what I mean there's one
thing okay so like we were talking to
said I don't know if this is because I'm
getting old I don't think so because I
thought this when I was younger too this
is why I was not into like Motley Crue
or like all that kind of more mainstream
kind of music because it just seemed
like the people were just like dummy
heads and it's like they were just doing
this [ __ ] because they thought that they
that it would make them cool I guess so
it's like hey I'm gonna run around the
you know I'm gonna run around this hotel
naked and like trash everything and like
they set [ __ ] on fire and like it you
know it's like what if you're in the
next room over and you were like man
shut up they're kind of like the young
scene kids that we know yeah and they
don't really come from anything they
live in [ __ ] terrible [ __ ] houses
and it's like a rough family isn't [ __ ]
you don't mean and imagine that they
just stumble into a bunch of Fame and a
bunch of money they would go [ __ ]
it's a recipe for yeah and that's what
they were doing
destroying hotel rooms and they're just
basically California white-trash kids
yeah yeah no they don't know the [ __ ]
they're doing and you know it ended up
like biting him in the ass like later on
after they made a lot of beds you know
Vince Neil like ended up killing the guy
from Hanoi Hanoi Rocks yes they were
drunk driving yeah you know and also
Vince Neil's daughter died of cancer
that was a business obviously but the
drunk driving thing that could have gone
either way to this [ __ ]
what's-his-name was drunk too they were
all drunk yeah they were getting to a
damn car whether you're the driver or
the passenger you're responsible yeah he
asked me you know the law is gonna say
something different yeah that the
drivers responsible but if you got egged
two dudes and they're both blast and
they both get in that car they're both
guilty yeah welcome passenger knows what
was going on um also dinner one of them
died of a heroin overdose and then was
brought back yes 96 Nikki Sixx died of
heroin every briefly yeah and you know
it's just like terrible she's like I
said they were all like [ __ ] each
other's girlfriends like you know what I
mean like [ __ ] Tommy Lee punched a
woman in the face she was a [ __ ] though
yes she was she was crazy too that's
another thing is that the women were the
women in some ways were worse than them
yeah because they were just kind of like
parasitical they just wanted to you know
they just wanted to hang out hang out
with rock stars and then they treated
rock stars like [ __ ] tried to control
woman [ __ ] you know it was just like
just terrible people all around yeah I
can see it though I mean [ __ ] they were
in their 20s yeah you know with all that
money what I think that she would go bad
if you don't have a history having money
yeah I do really like that's because
they you just rolls it away man because
you never had it you can just do
whatever you want to do yeah Nikki Nikki
had like a [ __ ] thousand dollar a day
heroin had it have it and he didn't
think that was a big deal I just I can't
imagine you go you go from just like
living basically in [ __ ] poverty to
been able to afford $1,000 a day just on
heroin and not really think and not
think anything about it yeah like I said
I don't there's a lot of money
I don't even know how all of I mean all
of them are still alive right how can oh
yeah their lives yeah I think they're
over and it was funny how their to call
him Mick Mars the old man and I think he
was thirty thirty one at the time yeah
maybe
well he was you know he's only good man
well when you're like 18 19 20 years old
a thirty year old does seem like an old
person so much didn't really say so in
the movie but based on what what I had
read what I had heard it was actually
MIT McMorris was the brains behind the
brains and the music really behind the
whole band and he was the one that kept
them all kind of in line and kept that
machine rolling and they do kind of
imply that in Lima because with a guy
that plays Mick Mars is like a lot more
stable he's a lot you know he gets drunk
too and like he does drugs and [ __ ] too
but he kind of like diesel he's kind of
more an adult you know he's already got
like an ex-wife I think at that point
and he's got like a house and everything
so he kind of keeps things from getting
too crazy although he doesn't always
succeed because the other three or such
Jack it tends to be rolling his eyes in
the background whenever they're doing
whatever they're doing stupid [ __ ]
because well because like I said as you
would like once you're 30 32 years old
you man you've already got one marriage
behind you and all this other case
you're like whatever like you know they
parties I gotta go again and they go
about his he had a big bone problem with
the spine and every yes they get into
that spine constantly hurt him I felt
like there was quick-setting
concreteness spine yeah he had to get
hip replacements I think because that
was at one point like when he'd get one
they came out of the hospital I think
they'd given him new hips at that point
I mean I think they likes cuz I haven't
read the book um you know I know a lot
of the Motley Crue stories because you
know they're famous and I kind of grew
up around that time and you couldn't
really avoid them even though like yeah
you know I wasn't a big fan or anything
but so I know like a lot of the famous
stories about Ozzy Osbourne of the ants
and they had a great look they did
actually the shout of the shouts of
devlop yeah they're look good it kind of
had an early goth cow in a way kind of
like a god yeah well a little with like
it's a little bland yeah yeah we're and
they made a lot of jokes in the movie
about them wearing their girlfriends
pants which they did well yeah Vince
boots Vince Neil was like top was he was
really bitching because he's I guess his
won his first [ __ ] girlfriend that um
had that $800 white leather pair of
pants and he was always wearing yes and
then I think you yeah she took him back
and he was more upset about that double
losing the girlfriend though like as she
was she was pretty Conte I guess at
least in the movie she might be a
perfectly at first in a real life I
don't know well be they want on that
thing
yeah I mean like I said kind of
everybody was awful people but in but in
that sense it's like fun to watch them
like look at those idiots it's funny is
it like the whole band groupie thing is
a thing of the past that's not really
happening much anymore yeah that seemed
like it was kind of like an ad yeah
everybody been Amin on everybody we know
Ana bands always like cooking you know
yeah it's like you don't start a band to
get laid anymore that worked up until
the 80s maybe the early 90s and then
after had admirers but it's not like it
was it's not like it was you don't get
like it's kind of like yeah like all the
heavy well it depends on the genre -
yeah cuz it's like it seems like you
know Motley Crue that's heavy metal and
[ __ ] like that in the 80s that was more
yeah you know you got like all these
like skanky what's like being like yeah
hey I'll blow you whatever but it's like
you know what I mean other genres didn't
really happen well they also pointed out
that whenever they pulled into town the
first place they went was the strip club
that's where they started drinking and
doing all their stuff in the strip club
yeah before the shows yeah so vomiting
on strippers yeah yeah dude wake up five
o'clock in the afternoon yeah let's go
bar pokers yeah and then like their
manager like [ __ ] it was I think it was
Tommy Lee like their manager they had to
like handcuff of to the bed so he
wouldn't like get up and cause any more
trouble
yeah it was like he a blacked out and
he's like he's gonna wake up and like do
some [ __ ] he doesn't remember they might
be really fast I set fire to expensive
hotel rooms by bid by letting off
fireworks shooting fireworks at Nikki
Sixx I was asleep in bed like you do
through a television out the window of
an expensive hotel and landed on the
guy's jet Mercedes yeah crushed it
busted up a guy's man they said it was
an accident
yeah and then kept throwing
yeah look that was an accident too
didn't matter they had money they could
pay for anything well that's probably
what they figured yeah you know what I
mean
but yeah so like I said it's it's almost
kind of like if you if you guys remember
like vh1 behind the music it's it's like
that but movie form with lots more
titties and swearing yeah you know what
I mean so if you like that kind of thing
cuz they you know I mean obviously
because it's just like a short movie
they kind of have to skate over a lot of
stuff they do get into like the shitty
stuff because you can't avoid it like I
said about Vince Neil's daughter dying
and killing you know and him killing
that guy in the car crash and you know
the heroin and all that other stuff but
it it follows very much that vh1 behind
the music arc where it's like oh we're a
scrappy young band and we're like we're
now we're like millionaires of this and
then everyone's on heroin and everyone's
like Anna's just like this terrible and
then they show them like now and they're
all fat I don't I don't think they were
all on her and was just Nikki Sixx's
mostly heavy they were doing other drugs
though they did a little bit of
everything
I think they yeah they're kind of like
big coke heads and so yeah I think but
yeah so he was the only one that
actually like died from that and then
had two burgers that was like a funny
scene one yeah when he died and he was
in the ambulance and they were just like
gonna let him go cuz he was dead and
like the one guy the ambulance was like
a big fan he's like this is Nikki Sixx
man I gotta bring adrenaline yeah twice
his [ __ ] heart and whatnot he pulled
the pulp fiction on him yeah yeah so if
you like Motley Crue even if you don't
it's still pretty entertaining like if
you're even if you're not into the band
I thought it was just fun Dana gets
funky it's pretty fun watch you know
just like I said it's it's a definitely
good drinking movie yeah and you know it
came out a while back that somebody
asked us to do it and I was like oh yeah
we saw that let's do it
you
okay so the third movie we saw this week
we actually got off our asses and went
to the theater to see Midway yeah I
thought this one was gonna be about like
Ford versus Ferrari but innokentiy is
but Ford versus Ferrari was better even
though this is a good movie yeah I saw
the original and the original was like a
half Japanese and half American effort
to put the tail of the Battle of Midway
together and you kind of saw the battle
from both sides and this also was like
that it did show some Japanese studio
symbols like they were involved there is
a lot of Japanese language in it
and there was a lot of there was like a
lot of Chinese investment in this movie
also
yeah they mentioned the Chinese with
some of the guys Doolittle's bombing
raid yeah D the problem with the movie I
thought was that the CG kind of took me
out of it sometimes yeah me too the it's
not bad CG it's just that what they
tried to do is very large in scope like
from when you see the back of a big
carrier the carrier leaves a pretty big
wake behind it and it just has a certain
look and the look of the wake didn't
look right you could tell that it was
not real and when planes hit the water
it just didn't that's not the way it
looks I mean I've seen that I've seen
the war footage of lions hitting the
water and it just just didn't look it
just didn't really look all that right
but the acting was really solid it had
about half the cast of Alita battle
angel in it yeah there was a bit of yeah
it sold it played like her boyfriend or
whatever yeah
the acting was really good it was
accurate the movie was pretty accurate I
did I looked up later on to see how
because I was curious I had I don't
think I ever saw because the original
Midway will the movie came out in 1976
Charlton Heston wasn't it right yeah I
think I don't know if I saw that I
probably did I've seen like so many
movies but um but this one seemed like I
was curious to see like how accurate the
[ __ ] was and this is actually almost
entirely historically accurate there's
just like a little a couple little
things like those two those two pilots
that got ejected
and they got they got taken by the
Japanese they said they they actually
were not killed on the same day as the
battle that was actually two weeks later
right and they were actually tortured
and stuff um how they were killed
because they only showed one of them
getting killed in the movie like with
the anchor and they they said that's
similar to how they were both got killed
I think they tied them to gas cans and
like threw them overboard they didn't
show the second guy getting killed but
they said so that was a little
inaccurate but other than that it's
fairly accurate there was just like a
couple things like one character like
was switched out for another one and
stuff like that but other than that it
kept pretty much - yeah how the [ __ ]
really happened some of the scenes when
they were doing the dive bombing on the
Japanese ships I mean it looked really
good but then sometimes it started to
just become overload where there's too
many airplanes in frame and it just it
starts it starts to become a little too
surreal I mean that's just that's just
what it seemed like to me sometimes the
angles didn't quite look right and the
distances didn't really look right I got
you know I'm talking about bas you get
that sometimes I was pulled out of the
movie because things just didn't look
natural didn't look right that's
something that but it's like not so much
in the battle scenes like that kind of
threw me off too but it's like it was
even in scenes where you know there
wasn't any battle stuff going on like
even when they showed like you know
people standing on like an aircraft
carrier and like there's like this weird
kind of like blurring around the edges
of their figure I guess because of
green-screen and the lighting was just
like very weird and like very flat
so it almost seemed like the whole thing
almost looked like a dream sequence yeah
except it's not supposed to be like it
just it didn't look realistic and they
made some scenes that were kind of
almost retro out of it out of the first
movie so do you
you neither supposed to be realistic or
is it you have to you have to pick a
lane yeah like for instance you know
they're flying along and I think it's a
I think it's a dauntless or Douglas I
don't remember what it was that damn I
think was a dauntless it was that
torpedo bomber two-seater was I I don't
remember I don't they didn't think they
anyway the canopies open and their masts
are off and they're flying you know
probably like 200 knots and they're
talking to one another
yeah and it's quiet no doesn't go that
way I mean in the hundred and first
whenever we flew with the doors open it
was like opening up the door to hell
yeah there's nothing but pandemonium out
there you know 200 mile an hour winds
and then the [ __ ] scream [ __ ]
propwash and [ __ ] you can't you can't
talk to somebody with canopy open
talking to the guy in the back that's
something out of movies yeah but just
kind of took me out of it I was like no
that can't happen because you know that
big old radial engine was sitting with a
friend there's no mufflers on it the
headers [ __ ] exit right there in
front of the cockpit you know it's just
deafening that's the thing though it's
like it's hard to do because I mean any
kind of movie like this where they're
recreating like very famous battles very
famous incidents it's like you have I
guess you have to have that type of
stuff in the movie like for suspense and
like tension purposes because you have
to have like the you know the pilot and
the bet and the guy in the back like
talking to each other even though in
real life they can't because you can't
hear each other because otherwise it
would just be like closed in and there
would be nothing and yeah the audience
wouldn't know it was going on
necessarily yeah and there wouldn't be
any like you know you wouldn't feel any
you know fear for the pilot or anything
like that because you wouldn't be able
to see their face or you'll be able to
hear them and you weren't really sure
what was going on you would just see the
plane I think they usually had like some
kind of throat mounted microphone and
they had a math song yeah time you know
so really it's kind of what you heard
from the inside of the [ __ ] that's more
what you heard you know like in Star
Wars a new hope that you know the very
first Star Wars movie where they're
running down the tenth trench that you
know the Death Star trench you know
that's what it sounds like you know yeah
right five runyan just a bunch of dudes
talking and it's not really a
naturalistic sound because it's coming
off their larynx yeah and that's really
there wasn't any of that in the movie so
you didn't really get that feeling that
you're listening to groups of guys
fighting from airplanes you know it's
there's recordings of it you can listen
to it yourself yeah like I said I guess
for cinematic purposes they have to do
it like but like I said if you're
to make something like realistic kind of
it's kind of hard to like find a way at
work right I have to pick a lane it's
easy and be theatric or s be realistic
and it's kind of mix and tried to mix it
it just but you know what beside from
all that it was a good movie I mean I
liked all I especially liked the guy
that played best I guess was his name
like dick best the you know the kind of
maverick pilot characters late he played
that the bounty hunter and uh and uh
Elliot of battle Angela's face cut off
that's right
yeah he's British it'd me you're
Australian or Britain or something like
that yeah they're all the same oh you
not America but yeah but yeah so I've
he's the character that you I guess
you relate the most to because he has
the most screen time he has the most
backstory like with his wife and
daughter you know and he has I feel like
he had the most personality because like
a lot of the other characters like you
know Patrick Wilson's character and like
um you know Dennis Quaid is in it Woody
Harrelson is in it but they don't get a
lot of screen time and you don't really
get to see like their background or
their story or anything like that so I
feel like I'm glad that they kind of had
the best character in there I mean it's
a real guy obviously he was based on a
real guy um but I like that he was in
there and they gave him more of a
backstory like you know with his family
and everything because he's somebody
that you could kind of get into the
movie with because other than that it's
just like a bunch of dudes stand around
like what are we gonna do with the
battle and stuff like that so there's
not you don't really get like a lot of
emotional connection they followed some
of yamamoto story they did yeah okay but
they didn't follow any other Japanese
people story which I think they should
have thrown in this they should have
actually of a couple of Japanese as a
mirroring type of yeah because the idea
the original movie Midway was a joint
effort between Japan the United States
to make a movie about this battle yeah
and I don't even think any maybe in the
Japanese version to edit might be
slightly different maybe there's me yeah
that's possible maybe possible yeah but
I think it should have been one where it
was
should have had stories about the
Japanese guys and the American guys yeah
because you have to remember that the
Japanese guys are they're the good guys
from their point of view
they're trying to stop a damn big ol
fleet of ships from coming and [ __ ]
over Japan yeah you know and you know
the Navy pilots aren't they're not in
China you know chopping up people in
Nanjing they're not it's the army the
Navy there was two totally separate
factions in Japan there were kind of
rivals yeah they didn't even Kuwait and
cooperate hardly at all so the Navy
pilots kind of in their version of how
the war went was very different from say
like a Japanese army they didn't see
they wasn't the same fight for them yeah
so that's you know they were willing to
throw their planes on enemy ships
especially during you know when they
were still winning you know yeah they
were still kind of winning up until
Midway they were willing to kill
themselves too because if the US fleet
got within striking distance of Japan a
lot of women and children would be
killed and it wouldn't it is like
sixty-three cities yeah like seven and a
half million civilians so yeah they
weren't they weren't doing it for
nothing yeah and in a way like I said I
really admire Q know the the first
Midway which came out in 1976 like you
said I really like war movies where they
try to see it from like both sides
because like you said the best you know
what we see is a villain I guess but the
best villains it's like you have to
understand that from their point of view
they were the good here are the good
guys it's like and they were trying to
you know fend off so it's like they had
went wives back at home and yeah it's
just same as we did so it's so I admire
that they try to do that like you said I
do wish I mean they did go into some of
the Japanese characters but mostly it
was the military characters they didn't
give any of them like a backstory about
their families or anything like that
they did show them doing like honorable
stuff like you know the captain of the
one ship that like went down with it
just because you know he thought he had
failed or whatever yeah and the guys
joined him and go down with the ship
with him yeah another thing that they
show is that and I like they pointed it
out you know that Japan was known for
those kamikaze attacks almost on
carriers
yeah but this movie pointed out that
Americans were trying to do that did
some of the Americans did it as well
right they shot down some bombers and a
bomber that was coming down so I think
it might have been a Mitchell bomber or
maybe a liberator I have to go and see
it but because it came from the island
it came from Midway Island when it was
going down damaged the dude tried to end
the whole bombing crew tried to fly it
right into into the aircraft carrier
yeah and Yamamoto I think it was
Yamamoto said that no they're not that
brave but then the XO was like no I
think they did try to hit us yeah and
then a couple other guys were trying to
tried the same thing you know if you if
you're gonna die anyway yeah you might
as well and so yeah and they did so they
did show that some of the Americans did
that and the Japanese were like oh well
okay yeah good on you yes because I
think they had an exam they had a
perception that the Americans wouldn't
do it
um but yeah some did in that battle and
like I said this is fairly this is a
fairly historically accurate it was
directed by Roland Emmerich who did
Independence Day 2012 he does all these
kind of big CGI heavy action movies he's
apparently been trying to get this made
for like a really long time but a lot of
studios didn't want to do it because he
was asking for like a [ __ ] ton of money
I think he was asking for like a hundred
fifty million or hundred million minimum
or something well he did eventually get
it you know he raised it and then like
Chinese investors gave him a little bit
also yeah it was some Chinese propaganda
in it yeah a little bit well I mean that
did happen it do happen they're not
making it up but I'm not making it but
they wanted to get that in but they
wanted to get that in there to make like
the heroic Chinese and like Japanese
[ __ ] them over and [ __ ] like that so
there is a scene about that in there but
like I said it is based on that did have
something that really happened so it's
not like they were just making it up but
yeah so he did finally get it made it
seems like it's getting kind of like
middling reviews and most of the ones I
read thought the same thing that like
the CG was kind of they were seeing the
same thing yeah it was kind of strange
it wasn't grandiose enough yes movie
should have been bigger yeah it should
have felt more real it should have had a
bigger all-star cast that's what it
should have been yeah I mean it's a good
cast it's like it everybody did a good
job should have had Tom Cruise in it
and admirals I'm gonna play to Admiral
they you know just needed a you needed
an all-star cast this way they would
have done it in Old Hollywood mean you
have to like you have to like admire the
ambition because like I said roland
emmerich is like this he's been wanting
to make a movie about the Battle of
Midway for like years and years and you
know the the budget was like kind of
getting in the way but you have to
admire the ambition of somebody I mean
he recreated the attack on Pearl Harbor
you recreated the whole entire Battle of
Midway light duty raid the Doolittle
raid like I was pretty much historically
accurately yeah I do just wish that the
CG or I wish that it would have looked a
little bit different because like I said
the lighting of it was very flat
you know the CGI was like it wasn't bad
it's not bad CGI but it wasn't [ __ ]
out stand it wasn't only believing yeah
it was just it was just a little bit off
and it just kept and like I said it
wasn't even just the battle scenes cuz
those looks pretty good um you know
other than like you said when the planes
caught fire and like fell in them it
didn't look entirely real yeah but even
like I said even when there was just
guys like standing talking on the
aircraft carrier you could tell that
they weren't there you know what I mean
so and it was like bothering me maybe
just because we like saw it but like I
said that's this is you know if you like
war movies and pretty like historically
accurate well I was a bachelor in a long
time this is like you know it's a really
enjoyable movie I was like you know even
though I kind of knew some of the
details of the battle and everything
like that just from history class in
school and whatnot but you know what I
mean it's but it's it's interesting to
see like you know the strategy and all
the like code breaking is like from both
sides and how the battle went and all
the characters and everything I do wish
they had done a little bit more
character development because it seems
the cast is so big and it's like they
can't spend a lot of time with everybody
this is more like a military strategy
movie rather than a character movie yeah
it wasn't quite the Saving Private Ryan
[ __ ] quality though yeah that's true
that's the thing that's it this should
have been almost like Saving Private
Ryan quality yeah it's still really good
though it's really good it's good
yeah it's just not really a minute the
story is so good yeah
that the visuals should have been yeah
[ __ ] the best you know the best money
could buy well like I said I think that
that happens a lot with these kind of
like big-budget like these big epic
scale movies I think the reason Saving
Private Ryan worked is because even
though it was you know an epic thing
going on in the background
well what yet one that was no CG but two
they kind of focused on a smaller story
within the larger context it's easier to
do which you know which that's easier to
do and it's easier to get people more
emotionally invested because you
actually care like if these people get
killed or whatever and I do feel like in
this one other than the best character
who you know had the most the you know
most larger-than-life personality he was
like the most likeable character and the
one you knew the most about so I I'm
glad that they had that character in
there at least I do wish that they would
have done a little bit more character
development just so you could kind of
get into people's heads more you know
what I mean but I can see how that
happens with you know a movie of this
scale where you're trying to
historically recreate you know a battle
that really happened I would like to see
if it's possible to remake Patton I mean
I'm surprised to know what's gotten
around to doing that yet Patton was a
masterpiece yes they did George Scott
played himself he didn't yeah he didn't
play Patton because if he heard recorded
to General Patton see pictures of him
you know he was a he didn't sound like
they didn't really look like that yeah
and in fact there were a lot of generals
like that like General Patton Patton was
just made they made a movie about him
and made him into an icon just based on
the back of that movie what one Jim of
the served with it misses men I would
have loved to have served with that
General Patton because it's not quite
that you know I mean that was the movie
version of bad yeah real life is never
as fun as it is the thing is with that
Patton movie is that all that all the
tanks were painted up American tanks
yeah the German tanks we're American
tanks painted up to be doing that digit
you would date you couldn't get a hold
of German Texan numbers in those days
but CG you could get German tanks you
could get it but who could you how could
you replace George C Scott who could who
could ever do that that's one of those
movies that I'm sure they'll get around
to remaking
someday because they'll because the law
says that you have to remake everything
they make you more of a [ __ ] though
okay there we go well I don't know we
can't say that you know because there
was some dialogue in that [ __ ] movie
about greasing the [ __ ] wheels of
their tanks with the guts of the enemy
all kinds of weird [ __ ] like I don't
know if they'd [ __ ] that would fly
nowadays in Hollywood well I don't know
if that's something that they really
said then yeah they would put it in
there probably I think I think that was
just I don't
evidently pretty much most of the
dialogue of the movie out of out of out
of Patton was a Patton like statement
Patton like statement yeah me then not
everything was yeah sounds like that
sounds good right yeah so he's kind more
of Legends and you know even though he
did exist yeah well I feel like that
happens with a lot of movies
particularly ones that are about a
character because like I said real life
is always more boring than yeah the
movies and that's why they have to like
sex everything up for the movies because
real life is kind of boring yeah he
wasn't a very big guy and he was kind of
had a nasally voice like yeah exactly
has how hand talk every day all talked
like that like everybody back in that
era maybe it was just because that's
what the recording sounded like the
recording is good so everybody just
sounded like Lego so you know like all
the newscasters and yes like that they
all kind of sound it like coming to life
well it's just kind of like the old
movies where like when you see like old
silent movies and stuff and like the
cameras were like and you know like old
warm or run footage like we were talking
about life with that documentary they
shall not roll where it's like you know
that that old footage was all hand
cranked so whenever they try to like
show it as a film everybody looks like
they're moving really fast or like all
jerky and [ __ ] it's like they don't
really move like that it was just like
the way they filmed it so I feel like
maybe that's what happened with all the
voices like maybe wish by boarding
technology but Midway we're actually
seeing Midway late it'll probably be out
of theaters pretty soon I think yeah I
thought this was its last week but I
guess not but you know you might want to
see if you like war movies you may want
to see this one before it goes yeah it's
decent it's it's it's got an awesome
story it's
true acting and it's really good yeah I
liked a lot of this movies a lot of this
movies very it is very good it's just
that it's this movie that this the
setting is so epic that if that CG isn't
[ __ ] spot-on it's not very believable
yeah but it's kind of piecemeal there
were certain times where it was clear it
was good but then there was a I don't
look like a video game oh yeah yeah know
what I mean and it was kind of like
throwing me out of it but I'm gonna
forgive it for that for that yeah I mean
you know like I said he's gonna want to
make this movie do you ever and you know
I'd say maybe he didn't get quite as
much money as he wanted to make he got a
lot but you know I don't think he got
quite as much as he wanted so it's very
that fast-paced it is cuz like I said
there's a lot of stories it's a very
complicated story because they start
they kind of start the beginning with
the attack on Pearl Harbor a little bit
before that they even get into the code
breaking angle yeah which I liked that
that was probably like my favorite
aspect of it like how they found out
like his Midway was supposed to be a
surprise attack like you know harbor was
and they thought that you know the
military thought they were gonna attack
somewhere else and then like they have
liked all the code-breaking and they
actually figured out no it was Midway
and you know the one guy I knew like
Patrick Wilson's character was trying to
tell everybody he's like no it's gonna
be a Midway it's not gonna be this other
I think they thought they were gonna
attack the Aleutian Islands right or
something like that they thought they
were gonna attack somewhere else and
rook but they you know they went through
all the code breaking and stuff so yeah
if you like war movies like I said it's
not the best war movie I've ever seen
but um you know he did seem to like take
care to make things accurate and you
know at the like at the end I like how
you know they had the real to picture
the real guy and like what ended up
happening to them and all this other
kind of stuff so you know it's even
though the CG was a little Lin
kind of took me out of it a little bit
but I'm you know that was kind of the
only problem I had with it I think I
just you know other than that it was it
was perfectly enjoyable and kept me
interested the whole time still you know
you